bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi encore de très grosses
manifestations de lycéens contre la loi
fillon ils étaient quinze mille à
bordeaux entre 30 et 60 milles à paris
où des casseurs ont pillé des magasins
et agressé des manifestants à
l'assemblée françois fillon défend son
texte point par mois
situation tendue au liban après
l'assassinât de rafic hariri ses
partisans ont pris pour cible des
intérêts syriens l'armée a été placée en
état d' alerte pour éviter des incidents
la syrie plus que jamais dans le
collimateur de la communauté
internationale le bilan en 2004 de
l'insee ils confirment la vitalité
démographique de la france 797 1000
naissances l'an passé le mariage est à
la baisse le pacs à la hausse paris
limite les dégâts dans la sphère
executive life cette affaire de portage
illégal mettant en cause le crédit
lyonnais
un accord provisoire est en bonne voie
avec les américains juste avant le début
du procès mais il faudrait tout de même
débourser 525 millions de dollars
le fabuleux bilan des deux robots spirit
et opportunity envoyés sur mars
après un an de service la nasa s'attend
maintenant à les voir s'éteindre d'un
jour à l'autre
ils ont notamment permis de confirmer la
présence d'eau autrefois sur la planète
rouge enfin la mort de pierre bachelet
chanteur discret on refrains populaires
comme les corons il était très malade il
avait 60 ans
les jours face le gouvernement recule
mais les lycéens semblent donc toujours
aussi déterminée contre la loi fillon il
y avait beaucoup de monde dans la rue
aujourd'hui encore malgré les vacances
des élèves des enseignants et aussi
malheureusement quelques dizaines de
casseurs qui ont perturbé le défilé à
paris nabila taboury stéphanie lavoie
dion les uns vivent leur première manif
les autres sont à peine plus rodé alors
forcément les slogans ne sont pas encore
tout à fait au point
pour autant la mobilisation ne faiblit
pas et même si françois fillon a
suspendu la récente du bac
les lycéens ne lui faut toujours pas
conscience encore plus encadrement plus
de poids des surveillants plus de propre
mois des classes moins surchargé en
mettant des notes de vie scolaire et des
bavures continuent aux côtés des lycéens
les enseignants la fsu leurs principales
fédérations appelaient à la grève mais
ils n'étaient que quelques milliers à
manifester pour seniors sont pour nous
ce sera beaucoup plus efficace
en tout cas de cette greny scène
émergent déjà une figure constance
blanchard présidente de lunel le
principal syndicat lycéen
cet élève de terminale littéraire
multiplie les interviews même la
télévision japonaise l'a repéré
plutôt bon enfant la manifestation a
malgré tout été émaillée d'incidents
une centaine de casseurs face à autant
de crs
bilan quatre blessés légers et quelques
voitures endommagées à bordeaux
l'ambiance est tout aussi électrique
quatorze mille lycéens dans la rue c'est
trois fois plus que la semaine dernière
la culture encore à prendre les choses
comme ça ses droits et sans imagination
malgré les vacances scolaires a lyon ils
étaient plus d'un millier lycéens
épreuves confondues
la mobilisation n'est pas prête de finir
grèce des manifestations sont déjà
prévues pour les prochains jours les
manifestations également dans une
quinzaine d'autres villes
à retenir en particulier l'importance du
cortège des cortèges à la réunion ils
étaient entre 5 et 6000 au total et
notamment 3000 dans les rues de saint
denis de la réunion ce soir l'ump par la
voix de bernard acoyer évoque les
manipulations dont seraient l'objet les
lycéens par les syndicats d'enseignants
c'est aujourd'hui vous le savez que le
projet fillon était examinée à
l'assemblée la gauche demande toujours
un retrait pur et simple du texte
alexandre kara zidène berkous ambiance
studieuse à l'assemblée nationale mais
entre la gauche et la majorité
la tension est palpable surtout
lorsqu'on évoque les manifestations je
n'aurai pas la cruauté de vous rappeler
combien d'enseignants et de lycéens
manifestaient dans les rues de notre
pays lorsque vous étiez vous-même
membres de la majorité
alors si le gouvernement a revu sa copie
sur le bac c'est bien sous la pression
des lycéens mais aussi des députés
grognon de l'ump les enseignants
je suis en train de me dire pour les
entendre notamment dans ma
circonscription que les français sont
presque au bord de l'overdose aux
réformes
dans la majorité certains n'apprécient
pas le calendrier d'autres n'aiment pas
beaucoup la méthode on ne réformera pas
contre les lycéens on réformera pas
contre les enseignants on ne réformera
pas contre les parents d'élèves une
cette fois pour le ps pas de guérilla
parlementaire met un zéro pointé pour
l'action du gouvernement
notre système d'éducation a été
littéralement séné à blanc par des
suppressions massives de postes et de
crédit malgré ces critiques l'avenir du
projet fillon dépendra bien moins du
débat parlementaire que de l'assiduité
des lycéens à manifester contre la
future loi
en tout cas est lié à ces derniers jours
comme un parfum de déjà vu depuis
quelques années les réformes de
l'éducation semble vouée à l'échec
plusieurs ministres en ont fait les
frais à droite comme à gauche
laurent différence magique c'est la
dernière victime en date luc ferry en
2003 il propose une réforme sur
l'autonomie des universités c'est un
échec
conséquence il quitte le gouvernement
son regret un manque de soutiens y
compris dans son propre camp
si vous ne laissez pas le temps à
l'opposition de critiquer les lois de la
majorité et que c'est déjà à l'inter de
la majorité que le ministre ait plombé
c'est extrêmement difficile d'avancer
depuis plus de 20 ans les ministres
passent le besoin de réformes demeure
1984 la réforme scolaire fait rage
public contre privé le ministre soldats
savary tombent au champ d'honneur
deux ans plus tard c'est au tour d'alain
devaquet sa réforme sur l'autonomie des
universités vole en éclats lui aussi
claude allègre lui voulait dégraisser le
mammouth en 2000 c'est le mammouth qui a
eu sa peau
on se trouve dans une confrontation avec
des corporations et donc à partir de ce
moment là c'est très toujours très
difficile
les corporations la tendance c'est de se
replier sur soi certains ont gardé leur
place tout de même en 94 françois
bayroux veut t'aider l'enseignement
privé plus d'un million de personnes lui
dise non car en france réformer n'est
pas simple j'ai pensé à une opinion sur
l'école il a la sienne mais il ya autant
d'opinions sur les colts il ya de
français donc déjà c'est très difficile
de mettre tout le monde d'accord quand
tout le monde a une opinion sur quelque
chose
enfin il ya les récidivistes en 95 la
réforme des iut capoter le ministre de
l'époque reculait il s'appelait françois
fillon la situation au liban trois jours
de deuil national ont été décrétés après
l'assassinât de rafic hariri les écoles
les commerces sont restés fermés mais la
colère gronde chez les partisans de l'ex
premier ministre des intérêts syriens
s'étaient pris pour cible l'armée a été
placée en état d' alerte sur place
thierry curtet frédéric bonne la ville
natale de rafic hariri a connu toute la
journée une situation tendue
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
bloquer les carrefours allant jusqu'à
frapper les travailleurs syriens de
saïda à 40km de berry dans la capitale
deux jeunes gens ont sillonné les rues
arborant drapeaux noirs et portraits de
l'ancien premier ministre
les cortèges partait et revenait du même
endroit là où la bombe a explosé
le cratère explique la méthode de
l'assassinât
il semble que les centaines de kilos
d'explosifs était enfouie sous la
chaussée les jeunes observent écoeuré le
futur c'est noir
pourquoi parce que il était le père de
vélo et malheureusement on a on en parle
de nuit dont c'est la merde juste au
dessus de leur tête il constate le
chemin parcouru depuis la guerre
l'entrepreneur hariri a rénové le
premier ministre hariri a lancé les
programmes
certes il a lourdement endetté le liban
reconnaît à la halle berry donne
mais le pays a changé de visage
l'attentât réveille chez lui de vieux
traumatismes et les ps on vit voilà
l'été la guerre commencée il est plat
mais comment on peut faire la guerre
maintenant le temps des larmes et des
condoléances au domicile du premier
ministre marwan hamadé fut très entouré
l'ancien ministre de l'économie fut
victime il ya quatre mois d'un attentat
dont il a lui échappé et le désespoir va
gagner les masses et il faut s'opposer à
cela il faut créer au liban une
situation de type craignant il faut
faire en sorte que nous puissions
imposées au régime policier en place et
instituteurs de laisser la place à une
vraie démocratie
rafic hariri était l'homme le plus
protégé du liban le plus riche le plus
reconnu à l'étranger
une sorte d'app châble pensait-on c'est
aussi ce que la tante a voulu détruire
le bilan a été revu à la hausse il y
aurait 15 morts et selon les autorités
il s'agissait d'un attentat suicide qui
a exigé un haut niveau de préparation
la revendication publiée par un groupe
inconnu hier laisse tout le monde
sceptiques les soupçons se portent plus
que jamais sur la syrie malgré ses
dénégations
les etats-unis ont décidé de rappeler
leur ambassadeur à damas pour des
consultations
paris veut une enquête de dimension
internationale et puis vous le voyez
indignation à l'onu où une minute de
silence a été observée aujourd'hui
en bref encore à l'étranger israël
souffle le chaud et le froid ariel
sharon
annoncé tout à l'heure que le retrait
de la bande de gaza serait effectué en
coordination avec les palestiniens
dans le même temps l'état hébreu prévoit
de construire en cisjordanie une
nouvelle colonie susceptibles d'héberger
une partie des sept ou huit mille colons
qui doivent quitter gaza
commentaire du premier ministre
palestinien ahmad qoreï israël se moque
de nous fin de citation
en france la polémique autour d'une
libération didier tallineau 39 ans
condamné récemment à 30 ans de prison
pour le meurtre de deux femmes a été
autorisé à quitter sa prison pour raison
de santé il est atteint d'un cancer
les familles des victimes sont indignés
elle dénonce une manipulation
le garde des sceaux dominique perben
vient de demander une nouvelle expertise
reliait climat christophe de balan bras
il habite le domicile de ses parents
depuis deux mois
aperçu ce matin caché sous son manteau
didier tallineau deux fois condamné à 30
ans de réclusion criminelle est
aujourd'hui libre de ses mouvements pour
raisons médicales
une décision que ce couple ne comprend
pas eux qui ont perdu leur fille sous
les coups meurtriers du condamné
là on est détruit on vit un enfer tous
les jours et lui skréla chez sa mère en
vacances c'est quand même pas mal
malade parmalat ma fille allait le droit
de mourir chez elle et pourquoi les la
droite elle mourrait chez sa mère qui
meurent en prison point final
décrit comme extrêmement dangereux lors
de ses deux procès pour meurtre en 2001
et 2002 didier tallineau ne devait pas
être libéré avant 2027
mais atteint d'un cancer de la plèvre il
a pu bénéficier deux ans plus tard de la
loi kouchner comme tous détenus dont le
pronostic vital est engagé
sa peine a été suspendue en toute
légalité sa remise en liberté sa
suspension de peine pour être exact a
été prononcée par une juridiction
collégiale c'est-à-dire par trois
magistrats qui avaient l'entier dossier
de monsieur tallineau qu'ils savaient
pourquoi il avait été jugé pourquoi il
avait été condamné
donc ils n'ont certainement pas pris
leurs décisions à la va vite
le garde des sceaux dominique perben a
cependant demandé qu'une nouvelle
expertise évalue l'état de santé du
condamné
si une amélioration notable devait être
confirmée didier tallineau pour est
immédiatement retourné en prison justice
encore avec la relaxe en appel de quatre
mères de famille interpellée pour avoir
mendié avec leurs enfants pour éviter
ces pratiques la loi sarkozy sur la
sécurité avait créé un nouveau délit
celui de privation soins une loi
invoquée pour la première fois dans
cette affaire en appel mais les juges
ont estimé que l'infraction n'était pas
constituée dans ce cas précis il s'agit
de femmes de la communauté roms venus de
roumanie
reportage ça la soul à michael cariou la
scène est presque ordinaire dans nos
grandes villes
une femme mendiants un enfant dans les
bras un acte que la loi française à 6001
délits de privation de soins angelica
goeman mendiait avec son fils sur les
champs elysées lorsqu'elle a été
interpellé par la police il ya deux ans
au juge
cette mère de quatre enfants a expliqué
qu'elle n'avait que la mendicité pour
vivre et personne pour garder ses
enfants dans la caravane
elle se défend de les avoir utilisés jeu
pas pour ça or gagner l'argent pour
amener mon enfant pour je ne sais pas
comment dodo
comment il s'appelle avec
pour profiter et mon endroit la femme se
défend aussi d'avoir fait mendier ses
enfants mais lorsqu'elle vous nous
montrez comment elles s'y prenaient
enfin leur réflexion sans équivoque mens
pas je fais des travailleurs et le faire
avec ma maman foch d'état faisait
comment alors marcher marcher à 7 ans
alicia donc bien arpenter les rues la
main tendue tous les enfants d'angelina
goeman sont aujourd'hui scolarisés mais
elle continue à mendier de temps en
temps son mari nettoie les pare brise au
carrefour arrivé de roumanie il ya cinq
ans sans papiers ils ne peuvent pas
légalement travailler et ne bénéficie
d'aucune allocations sociales sous
l'autoroute a86 à quelques pas du stade
de france
le bidonville où vit nadia bébé car
l'autre mère de famille poursuivie pour
avoir menti avec les enfants ici pas
d'eau pas de sanitaires c'est la rue
elle avoue sans détour qu'avec un enfant
les gens donnent deux fois plus et la
semaine dernière encore elle a pris avec
elle le petit dernier la petite leur
trop je l'emmène avec moi s'il n'est pas
à l'école sinon je vais manger seul
malgré le risque d'emprisonnement
quelques femmes roms continuent à
mendier avec leurs enfants mais elle
confie le fait rarement et dans des
lieux moins exposés que les champs
elysées pour éviter la police la
guadeloupe à nouveau touchée par un
tremblement de terre séisme de magnitude
5,7 sur l'échelle de richter qui a été
ressenti dans le sud de l'île et
l'archipel des saintes
il ya eu quelques scènes de panique des
dégâts matériels et quatre blessés
légers des témoins ont indiqué que la
mère avait changé de couleur devenant
bleu ciel comme dans un lagon
il ya trois mois un tremblement de terre
avait déjà fait un mort et plusieurs
dizaines de sans abri en guadeloupe en
sardaigne le paquebot pris dans la
tempête hier avec 790 personnes à bord
est finalement arrivé à bon port mais
avec des passages et éprouvée yann genty
elle s'accroche sa bouée de sauvetage
comme si elle ne voulait plus la quitter
comme si la tempête ne s'était pas
arrêtée les voilà pourtant sur la terre
ferme
certains d'entre eux sont blessés hier
pendant de longues heures
le paquebot de ses passagers se
retrouvent est ballotté au milieu d'une
mer déchaînée de creux de dix à quinze
mètres sans radar un moteur en panne
leur navire était en perdition qui s'est
engouffrée elle a cassé les moteurs et
le navire chemise à dériver rives et la
vague vous l'avez vue et non non la
vague je n'ai pas vu il était 5 ou 6
heures du matin on a tous eu le
sentiment qu'on allait mourir avec des
taux il ya une première vague immense
qui a retrouvèrent toute une partie du
bateau et du pont supérieur
maintenant il faut que les autorités
enquêtent
à mon avis il ya une faute une erreur du
capitaine les parties les plus hautes du
navire ont été endommagé les vitres du
poste de commandement n'ont pas résisté
malgré ces dommages le paquebot a réussi
à rallier le port de cagliari en
sardaigne tôt ce matin après une
traversée très mouvementée arrivé à quai
les passagers des espagnols en majorité
ont pour la plupart tous décidé de
rentrer chez eux par le premier vol un
terrible accident de voiture tout à
l'heure sur l'autoroute a6 entre paris
et lyon à hauteur de sens
une mercedes a percuté un véhicule
d'assistance vide une intervention était
en cours
il y avait quatre passagers dans la
voiture ils sont tous morts sur le coup
le chauffeur âgé de 83 ans n'aurait pas
vu le véhicule les policiers en tout cas
n'ont relevé aucune trace de frein sur
la chaussée le bilan 2004 de l'insee il
permet de dresser un tableau de la
famille en france
principaux enseignements nous restons le
grand pays d'europe où on fait le plus
d'enfants
le mariage est à la baisse le pacs à la
hausse
anne guéri d'illiez rancoeur elle est
toute neuve cette petite lise né cet
après-midi dans une maternité qui ne
désemplit pas ici on affiche complet
tous les jours celle partout en france
2004 fut particulièrement prospère 797
1400 naissance soit 3500 bébé en plus
par rapport à 2003 et les mamans elles
n'ont peur ni d'une grossesse tardive
ni de la conjoncture parfois morose je
n'avais pas trouvé le papa encore donc
voilà la raison pour laquelle entre
autres j'ai attendu aussi longtemps on a
la situation professionnelle qui fait
qu' on part d'aller faire et quand on
décide de le faire c'est pas toujours au
moment de le faire
du coup aujourd'hui une mère sur deux à
30 ans ou plus et avec ces mamans plus
ou moins jeunes la france devance
l'italie ou l'espagne
au palmarès de la fécondité elle est en
deuxième position derrière l'irlande une
exception bien de chez nous disent les
sociologues plus le français est grognon
plus il fait des enfants français
conteste un petit peu une société qui
est trop financière trop simplement
économique
eh bien ils sont conséquents avec cette
analyse
et finalement ils disent qu'il n'y a pas
que ça qui est important dans la vie il
ya le fait d'avoir un projet de vie
familiale et d'avoir des enfants et dans
le fond il le met en pratique et pour
faire leurs enfants les français ne
passe plus nécessairement par les liens
du mariage plus de 47 % des naissances
hors mariage en 2004
c'est 10% de plus qu'il ya dix ans
économie avec la sphère executive life
la france va peut-être évité le pire à
quelques heures de l'ouverture du procès
un accord semble en voie de conclusion
avec le département des assurances de
californie le crédit lyonnais et le
consortium de réalisation c'est à dire
finalement le contribuable devrait tout
de même débourser 5 125 millions de
dollars pour ceux qui ont manqué le
début
explication françois beaudonnet josé
boulesteix
1991 le français crédit lyonnais rachète
une compagnie d'assurances californienne
en faillite executive life la sphère
passe alors inaperçu pourtant elle va
déboucher douze ans plus tard sur la
mise au jour de la plus grosse fraude de
ces quinze dernières années aux états
unis selon la loi californienne en tant
que banque étrangère et public qui plus
est le crédit lyonnais n'a pas le droit
d'effectuer cette transaction mais les
autorités américaines préfèrent laisser
faire du coup les français s'estimant
innocent refuse de négocier pendant
plusieurs années
du côté français beaucoup dit et anti
sme beaucoup d'imprévision beaucoup de
superficiel côté américain de la volonté
et une volonté de raquette qui est
arrivé à ses fins la position française
n'est pas tenable et un changement de
stratégie intervient alors au plus haut
niveau de l'état
au nom des intérêts financiers de l'état
le gouvernement continuera à rechercher
activement un accord qui soit cette fois
définitif avec les autorités américaines
l'accord définitif vient peut-être
d'être trouvée aujourd'hui à los angeles
quelques heures à peine avant
l'ouverture d'un procès fleuve au civil
deux des trois parties françaises le
crédit lyonnais et le cdr une structure
publique viendrait de transiger pour 525
millions de dollars dont 375 ont déjà
été versé une somme d'autant plus
importante si elle se confirme qu'elle
est à la charge du contribuable français
mais elle serait aussi largement
inférieur aux 5 milliards de dollars
demandés par les américains en bref les
conclusions de l'enquêté administrative
sur l'accident du terminal de roissy ont
été rendus publics
conclusion qui indique que des fissures
existait et dès le début dans la coque
de béton notamment en raison d'un
ferraillage insuffisant ou mal
positionné on l'évoquait dès la semaine
dernière c'est plus l'exécution sur la
conception qui serait donc mise en cause
c'est l'autre événement aéronautique de
l'année après le lancement de l'a380
dassault vient de dévoiler son nouvel
avion d'affaires le falcon 7x si vous
voulez vous l'offrir il faut compter
tout de même 29 millions d'euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent
mais les carnets de commandes sont déjà
pleins le secteur des avions privés est
en plein boom patrice pollet yann one 25
mètres de long autant de large
chez nouvel avion l'un des plus
imposants dans la catégorie des avions
d'affaires haut de gamme pour 29
millions d'euros selon les désirs du
client
l'intérieur peut ressembler à ça luxe
mais aussi tout ce qu'il faut pour
travailler pour le piloter un cockpit
ultra moderne
il n'a rien à envier l'airbus a380 c'est
du même niveau
l'avion se pilote avec des mini manches
et la présentation des informations est
poussé au maximum poussé très loin
l'intégration de manière à ce que les
choses soient extrêmement convivial
facile à comprendre que nous ce qu'on
appelle la conscience de la situation
soit excellente
contrairement à l'idée reçue ce ne sont
pas les vedettes du show biz qui
achètent en priorité ses avions 90 % des
acquéreurs sont des hommes d'affaires ou
des sociétés
à bord on travaille après les états unis
l'objectif visé par dassault aviation
c'est l'europe qui s'agrandit tous les
jours l'évasion du niveau économique
cantrell l'élargissement de l'europe va
faire que je lui ai besoin vont
augmenter dans un certain nombre de pays
nouveau en europe et donc tous ces gens
vont avoir besoin de se dépasser eux
aussi sur la totalité de la planète
impressionnant 23500 avions d'affaires
sont en service dans le monde contre
seulement 21 mille avions de ligne un
avion d'affaires décolle toutes les 45
secondes et 10 fois plus d'aéroport
peuvent les recevoir en 40 ans dassault
aviation a vendu 1800 falcone elles
placent aujourd'hui la france parmi les
premiers vendeurs de la planète
c'est autant d'argent qui contribuent à
la balance
de notre commerce extérieur comme chaque
soir cette semaine nous allons
maintenant en espagne qui sera dimanche
le premier pays à organiser un
référendum sur la constitution
européenne l'espagne immergé dans
l'union s'est par exemple l'une des
premières nations du continent pour
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers
le fameux programme erasmus et cet
engouement pour madrid ou barcelone
avait même donné lieu à un film on s'en
souvient l'auberge espagnole le titre
est bien choisi reportage à quarts dos
thierry breton tease ça louche prost à
la tienne il y à mille manières de se
souhaiter la fin de la session
universitaire italien portugais et
belges allemands ou français bénéficient
de cette fameuse bourse qui leur permet
de suivre
six mois durant leur formation à
l'étranger à part de l'union européenne
et c'est important de d'aller à la
rencontre d'autres personnes
c'est pas en restant en france que
construit pour ce construit une image de
l'europe
sur le campus universitaire de madrid on
boit dans toutes les langues et
l'espagne reste la destination
privilégiée des étudiants erasmus en
europe cet immense complexe peut
accueillir 60 mille étudiants et le
nombre d'élèves venus de l'étranger
progresse chaque année
alors qu'est ce qui peut bien attirer en
espagne les études ou la fête
je crois que c'est un peu les deux aces
les étudiants ont du temps de libre
c'est vrai mais ils étudient aussi alors
ça dépend vraiment des personnes
mais la formation à l'étranger coûte
cher 400 euros par personne et par mois
rien que pour ce studio
soraya emilie ont en partie financer
leur formation
elle se dit séduite par la qualité de
vie et de l'enseignement scolaire paraît
si le contact est étudiante en langues
elles sont titulaires d'une maîtrise et
espère passer leur master en espagne
c'est pour cela qu'elles ont décidé de
rempiler pour une nouvelle session de
six mois histoire de faire de nouvelles
rencontres l'environnement avec d'abord
un retour en provence dans la région
d'autres saints un sali depuis plusieurs
semaines par une pluie de sacs
plastiques en raison de la présence
d'une décharge à ciel ouvert
c'est en train de devenir un véritable
feuilleton des filets avaient été
installés pour retenir les ordures
ils ont à nouveau cédé après un coup de
vent sur place yannick aroussi
christophe la rocca
du canal de protéger des millions de
sacs poubelle une nouvelle fois échappé
de la décharge ont porté par un mistral
à plus de 100 kilomètres heure des
filets de protection
yves nouvelle fois éventré et le maire
d'istres commune voisine de la décharge
critique une nouvelle fois la gestion du
site dans la communauté urbaine de
marseille au dessus de 60 km on arrête
de décharger
s'il n'y avait pas eu de déchargement
croyez vous que nous serions dans cette
situation aujourd'hui
et c'est encore pire qu'au mois de
novembre donc je crois qu'il faut que on
arrête de nous prendre pour des
imbéciles
la communauté urbaine assure faire des
efforts les ordures sont actuellement
stockés dans leurs wagons
en attendant que le vent se calme
aujourd'hui hier une partie est joint
dimanche on arrêter le déchargement sa
empêché d'avoir des dispersions les
endroits où les filets ont cédé et donc
on reste il ya une mise en suisse à
tunis en sera ce contenu aujourd'hui
ironie du sort la semaine dernière
l'installation de ces nouveaux filets
beaucoup plus résistant a commencé mais
seuls 50 m sont en place il en reste
huit sans imposer d'ici la fin du mois
d'importants travaux de réhabilitation
du site sont contents mais la facture
nettoyage des abords compris et de
500000 euros
les ânes attendant le mistral souffle
toujours et les arbres se passerait
volontiers de ce genre de décoration
l'environnement encore à la veille de
l'entrée en vigueur du protocole de
kyoto les bouleversements climatiques
était au centre d'un forum aujourd'hui à
l'elysée et à cette occasion le chef de
l'état a fixé des objectifs plus
ambitieux que le protocole lui-même
divisé par quatre l'émission les
émissions de dioxyde de carbone d'ici
2005 jacques chirac a demandé au
gouvernement de réfléchir à des mesures
allant dans ce sens dans l'habitat et
les transports
ce gaz le co2 comme on dit dans les
cours de chimie est le principal gaz à
effet de serre et pour mieux comprendre
comment ils influencent le réchauffement
de la planète
des échantillons d'atmosphère de chaque
pays de chaque région sont prélevés
régulièrement dans le ciel par des
avions équipés vous allez le découvrir
d'un matériel spécial sophie mais elle
mathieu dreujou
ce jour là comme deux à trois fois par
mois ces jours de balade
le but n'est pas d'admirer le paysage
mais de capter l'air du temps au vrai
sens du terme car dans ces flacons c'est
bien de l'air est uniquement de l'air
qui est recueillie mais des lieux bien
précis juste au dessus de la forêt
d'orléans
nous sommes en mission scientifique à
travers la fenêtre du pilote un petit
tuyau branché sur l'extérieur il est
relié à une pompe et le tout est mis
sous pression non plus permis la con et
voilà maintenant l'air qui est
emprisonné dans la cour intérieure
retour sur terre nous sommes au
laboratoire des sciences du climat
c'est ici que le contenu des flacons va
être scrupuleusement analysés et ce qui
intéresse les chercheurs c'est de savoir
quel est le pourcentage de co2 contenu
dans l'atmosphère alors on s'intéresse
aussi aux deux parce que la composition
de ce gaz à effet de serre qui est
naturellement présent dans l'atmosphère
normalement a fortement augmenté depuis
l'ère préindustrielle en 150 ans
concentration a augmenté de d'environ
30%
car l'activité de l'homme par le biais
de l'industrie des transports et du
chauffage rejette des centaines de
milliers de tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
les chercheurs ont aussi remarqué que la
courbe du co2 se comportaient quasiment
de la même façon que la courbe de
température dans le monde et ce depuis
cent soixante mille ans ce qui veut dire
que pour prédire l'évolution du climat
dans le futur on doit comprendre
l'évolution du co2 de l'atmosphère aux
quatre coins du globe
et c'est ce qui est fait dans ce
laboratoire qui reçoit par mal des
échantillons d'air du monde entier de la
russie au mexique des états unis à
l'australie
toutes ces données sont entrées dans un
ordinateur et modélisés voici ce qu'elle
nous enseigne vous regardez la france en
irak en 2100 aurait des conditions de
température pratiquement chaque été qui
seront semblables à celles qu'on a
connues pendant l'été 2003 étaient six
certaines études récentes parle même de
11 degrés de plus d'ici la fin du siècle
à moins qu'une révolution technologique
permettent de freiner ce qui ressemble à
un emballement inéluctable et la france
vous aurez rectifié de vous-même entend
diviser par quatre ses émissions de co2
d'ici 2050 et non pas 2005 comme indiqué
par erreur
les sciences c'est l'heure du bilan pour
les deux petits robots envoyés sur mars
il y a un an leur vie touche à sa fin et
ce bilan est tout simplement fabuleux
oui mars a été comme la terre
aujourd'hui baigné par des océans à
nicolas chateauneuf eric de lannion on
se croirait presque sur terre en plein
désert et pourtant nous nous trouvons
sur mars
tel que l'a vu spirit le petit robot
américain cela fait maintenant plus d'un
an qu'il a déployé ses panneaux solaires
sur la planète rouge avec son frère
jumeau opportunity qui s'est posé aux
antipodes
depuis les deux robots nous envoie
régulièrement des photos
impressionnantes de la surface martienne
l'un d'eux a déjà parcouru près de 6 km
un véritable exploit lorsqu'on sait que
leur mission ne devait pas dépasser
trois mois malgré l'hiver martien et
c'est moins 85 degrés malgré aussi la
poussière qui se dépose sur les panneaux
solaires et réduit l'énergie disponible
voici deux photos prises à 11 mois
d'intervalle à gauche un cercle témoins
blanc à droite le même recouvert par une
fine couche de poussière entre mais pour
l'instant les deux rover roule toujours
il faut quand même comprendre que une
panne d'un d'une batterie ou un système
de communication peut finalement faire
que toute la mission s'arrête
brutalement
or pour l'instant à part quelques petits
problèmes sur une roue sur des panneaux
solaires un peu en sable et finalement
tout fonctionne bien à bord
thierry de continuer à gravir sa sa
colline il va atteindre prend le vent le
sommet bientôt et opportunity a est
sorti au bout de six mois de son cratère
il est allé voir le bouclier thermique
qui l'a aidé à se poser sur cette
planète et surtout à ceux freiner dans
les hautes couches de l'atmosphère et
maintenant il est en train de partir
vers un nouveau cratère qu'il atteindra
peut-être dans quelques semaines sur ces
images on peut suivre au quotidien et en
accélérer l'activité du rover
opportunity fait de déplacement et
d'analystes grâce au bras articulé des
deux robots c'est lui qui a eu le plus
de chance
non seulement il est tombé nez à nez
avec une météorite rarissime mais en
plus il a atterri au beau milieu d'un
cratère dont les rochers affleurant ont
révélé la présence passée d'eau liquide
à la surface de mars
pendant combien de temps et à quel
moment c'est la question qui obsède les
scientifiques car sans eau liquide
pendant des millions d'années mars a peu
de chance d'avoir un jour abrité la vie
peut-être que le moment où l'eau et des
liquides était très tôt dans son
histoire il ya plus de 4 milliards
d'années et que peut-être depuis
essentiellement parce que l'atmosphère a
disparu de cette planète est bien l'eau
il reste essentiellement gelé sans
nécessairement la possibilité ce que la
vie même si elle a démarré à l'époque et
puces pour suivre la surface de mars
très longtemps pour répondre à toutes
ces questions les scientifiques
disposent aussi de la sonde européenne
mars express
là aussi la mission continue en orbite
et les découvertes risquent de pleuvoir
dans les prochaines semaines la
politesse
reviendrait-elle à la mode pour la ville
de montpellier en tout cas c'est un
moyen de redonner le sens civique aux
plus jeunes
laisser sa place à une personne âgée
dire bonjour à son voisin une école des
bonnes manières a été installé dans un
quartier sensible
elle connaît un succès que personne
n'avait prévu hélène vernis françoise
mazou sur place la politesse et le
respect de l'autre ça t'apprend à la
maison neuf ans et puis ensuite à
l'école et puis dans l'entourage bonjour
merci au revoir
bonne soirée des attitudes des gestes et
surtout des mots pour mieux vivre
ensemble voilà ce qu'est la politesse
mais partant du principe que les bonnes
manières se perdent
l'idée est née à montpellier d'une école
du savoir vivre
je jette mon papier de bonbon dans la
rue au lieu de regarder dans la poche un
certain nombre de familles démissionne
et laisse aux éducateurs que ce soit
dans les écoles ou dans nos structures
le soin d'apporter les éléments
essentiels de de la politesse en disant
qu'on vous apprend à l'école on n'a pas
besoin de leur apprendre
face à ce constat la ville de
montpellier est donc prié devant chaque
semaine dans un centre socioculturel des
éducateurs prêche la bonne parole et
aborde les thèmes de la vie quotidienne
compass moquer faut pas se battre
faut pas faire de différence fatras de
vie et on se battait à 20 ans était
depuis se battre
maintenant si on n'est pas pour les
frappes au dessus pour tous les dames il
doit s'ennuyer
et le succès est au rendez vous déjà
deux établissements scolaires ont
inscrit à leur programme l'apprentissage
de la politesse en espérant ainsi lutter
contre la violence à l'école cinéma avec
la sortie demain du promeneur du champ
de mars
on en a parlé ici même un film qui
redonne vie à la légende de françois
mitterrand
chacun a son avis sur la question nous
avons demandé le leur à plusieurs
proches de l'ancien président à la
sortie de la projection chef vite imbert
mathieu dreujou le véritable françois
mitterrand aurait t'il prononcer ce
genre de phrase je suis le dernier des
grands présidents tous les proches de
l'ancien président sont formels c'est un
certain mitterrand que l'on découvrira
demain non pas une réincarnation
mais un personnage composée par michel
bouquet je retrouve même était
silhouette la nuque
dimanche c'est extraordinaire le regard
n'est pas le même le regard des
scénaristes lui s'arrête longuement sur
un moment douloureux de la fin de vie de
françois mitterrand les révélations sur
son rôle pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale aux côtés du régime pétainiste
mais le gouvernement de vichy ce n'était
pas la france et là le film fait mouche
le vrai mitterrand était indigné quand
on évoquait son amitié avec bousquet
l'ancien chef de la police de vichy les
mitterrandistes de coeur sont eux mêmes
troubles
sas a déclenché en lui une espèce de de
colère que bousquet rend bien dans le
film c'est quelque chose qui eux a
boosté le bouquet rend bien dans la zone
pardon autre temps fort autre sujet à
discussion les rapports entre mitterrand
et jospin tous ses rondeurs n'ont pas
fini de m'entendre les jospinien les
rocardiens georges marc benamou auteur
du livre qui a inspiré le film affirme
qu'il y avait plus qu'un malentendu
entre mitterrand et chose paris était
question me dire on participe à un
meeting de soutien jospin en 1995 ça
devait se passer dans le sud-ouest
mitterrand j'ai vu mitterrand attendre
le coup de fil et j'ai vu me terreur
effectivement être très très très dur
envers l'entourage de lionel jospin en
particulier daniel vaillant ça c'est la
vision d'aidé de ceux qui ont écrit le
livre tout ils ont bien droit
comme aurait dit françois mitterrand ce
serait une erreur d'interprétation que
de lire tu fume comme un film historique
neuf ans après sa mort les polémiques
sont retombés chacun retrouver son mythe
errant dans le film robert guédiguian
qui l'a réalisé espère lui que l'image
de l'ancien chef des temps sortira
plutôt grandi et sachez que histoires
courtes sur notre antenne consacre ce
soir son édition à robert guédiguian le
réalisateur à suivre à partir de 1h15 la
mort d'un chanteur populaire pierre
bachelet hauteur des corons c'était un
chez lui aujourd'hui des suites d'une
longue maladie selon la formule
consacrée
il avait 60 ans olivier les nous à
marie-hélène bonne
c'était trop bon
c'était chambre
monsieur
ils chantaient les corons le nord la
terre de pierre bachelet une éthique de
comportement de correction de green tech
grand que j'ai reçus ça il est né le
nord mais rêvait d'un autre horizon
pierre daschle et descend donc à paris
en 1974 compose la bande originale du
film emmanuelle
après la musique des bronzés font du ski
le chanteur sort un album personnel dont
la chanson elle est d'ailleurs et vendus
à un million et demi d'exemplaires et
rendent aveugle aux amoureux
elle a déjà ce peu de parfum qui rendent
bête ou les tubes s'enchaînent alors je
raconte la vie je la raconte pas ma
façon et c'est les petits instantanés
des petits scénarios comme sage
il détestait les paillettes du showbiz
admirait les grands navigateurs
solitaires normal de le retrouver en duo
ou micro avec florence arthaud il va
rester les jolies chansons
il va rester une âme ce qui est quand
même très important c'était pas
superficiel c'était pas du toc c'est un
vrai mec pierre bachelet ressemble
finalement à ses chansons un homme
simple
sans un homme devenu un peu malgré lui
un chanteur populaire qui un jour
images du concert de soutien à florence
aubenas et hussein hanoun hier à
l'olympia 2000 personnes pour écouter
charles aznavour patrick bruel bernard
lavilliers entre autres la grande sophie
2000 personnes parmi lesquelles des
hommes politiques nicolas sarkozy ou
lionel jospin concert également dédié à
la journaliste italienne julian à gré
n'a pour tourner également sans nouvelle
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi à 20h45 le match de l'espoir les
meilleurs footballeurs du monde
s'affrontent dans le stade mythique de
barcelone et les bénéfices du match
seront reversés aux victimes du tsunami
en asie du sud
juste avant la météo nathalie rihouet
12h55 dernier journal et se mettaient
dès 6h30 télématin dans les 4 vérités
roland sicard recevra ségolène royal on
se quitte sur ces images d'un saut en
parachute peu ordinaire le départ ne
s'est pas fait d'un avion mais du toit
de ce camion qui circulait sur le grand
fond de lisbonne 70 mètres de hauteur
seulement qui laisse quatre secondes à
peine pour ouvrir sa voile défi réussi
pour elrio part de 44 ans et on répète
n'essayez pas de faire la même chose à
demain
hier